we can't forget the corgis they were her
majesty's absolute favorite she grew up
with corgis her father george vi gifted
her a corgi when she was little and from
then i think a love affair was cemented
because the queen kept corgis for her
entire life and she was never without
them trailing behind her sort of yapping
at anyone that that dared to try and
stroke them they would only allow the
queen to stroke them and the queen would
often be the one to feed them and you
know hand selected cuts of rabbit i
hasten to add so who's going to look
after the corgis well she has two sandy
and mewick muic is named after one of
her favorite rivers in scotland the
corgis have actually already been given
to prince andrew he spent a lot of time
with the queen in the last months i
think he was one of the few who the
corgis didn't try and bite and he he
seemed to have a good rapport with them
so it was the queen's wish that um sandy
and muic went to andrew well as well as
her love of corgis which is of course
well known is her love of horses the
queen wasn't just a wonderful equestrian
a great horse woman who actually rode
well into her 90s and she was also a
very professional serious horse owner
she had a keen interest in horse racing
and she owns racehorses so the master of
the horse john warren who
actually walked behind her procession as
she went to lay in stage will be the man
in charge of working out exactly what
happens now to the queen's horses i do
know that it was her majesty's wish that
that love of horses and racing
is continued through the next generation
camilla queen consort is also a big fan
of horse racing and she also owns a
racehorse with the prince of wales so i
think there's every chance that she will
inherit some of the queen's racehorses
possibly some of them will be sold but
in terms of that affiliation between
royals and racing which has really kept
the sport alive in britain i think
that's going to be very much down to
camilla to continue the royals have
always had a love affair with horses i
mean in the queen's case that's through
racing she used to read the racing post
before she read anything else at
breakfast which she took of course out
of her tupperware containers but for the
other royals big love affair with polo
polo horses weren't the queen's thing
what she does have is a collection of
some very majestic
first class um horse races bred to race